[Music]
[Music]
yes i have another absolute lad for you
all again today today's guest has had a
huge rugby career which involves
starring for teams including otago the
highlanders tasman rico black rams
ospreys the pacific islanders and of
course he represented his country and
captain samoa however it's not just on
the field this man succeeded as his post
40 career has been an absolute
domination job as a scene and become a
coach mentor speaker and has recently
released a book tackle your success
which is sure to be a top seller so much
to talk about this in this one i'm
really looking forward to it with the
great lad filippo levy welcome brother
hey james either what a i'm
sure that was me i'm sure i'm sure
that's someone else that you're
mentioning hey bro uh i i love the intro
music i was actually dancing to it it
was just reminding me back in the in the
eighth or nineties when i was used to
dance at the clubs
uh anyway it's awesome to
yeah well sometimes but hey it's uh yeah
awesome to be on your show uh what a lad
so yeah thank you mate stoked to have
you on like i said so many teams you've
you've seen so much throughout your
rugby career and also post footy and um
i think you can uh inspire a lot of
people with especially that post-footy
transition that you've done and i know a
lot of people in the current climate are
in job transitions and things like that
so i think we can get a lot out of uh
your mind well i really hope so
i guess that's uh i mean as most people
that go through change and careers or
sports
uh were very similar uh and going
through those um the same experiences
and i think with um
woof woof the pandemic and uh covert you
know and the ongoing problems with
sports and you know bubbles and you know
the super rugby teams going down to
queenstown which is great for for
queenstown and dunnis
uh but you know i think um you know
probably
i think that they should have just added
awkward you know
you know what's happening really but hey
it's uh yeah so there's lots to talk
about this morning
and i want to start with your book
tackle your success um what inspired
this
um i guess with most things i um you
know i quite enjoyed tackling uh as
my career something i
i'm not saying that was well known for
but something that i worked hard to
improve on and
and and tried to be that um
you know to add value to the team so it
was always about
uh how can i make the impact the team
how can i change the game around by
doing one thing two things
you know because i'm not i'm very
different to like richie mccoy or to a
toy
a um you know to a a christie sort of
top uh tackler who chop tackles and gets
the ball like yeah you know i'm i'm six
foot five i'm like i want to go down
that bit low uh if i can if i can hit
i'll hit someone and make it count yeah
man i guess
so so i guess there's a lot of um a lot
of that and then looking through my my
challenges through
uh through rugby i thought hey
and can go for the transitioning process
that the pain the fear of what happens
next
i thought hey this is just like uh rugby
this is going to a professional
you know you're going to a new team a
new corporate team you're going to these
people who um who are different to you
who challenge you because i'm working
with women
uh people from different legends uh
different uh the ethnicities
uh because in rugby it's mainly you know
it's mainly
pakistan is maori you know that's that's
that's the the the the majority um if
they make up but when i work in the
corporate environment it was mainly uh
people from southeast asia india
uh china
philippines say you know americans
and so you gotta yeah so i thought okay
i needed to
to go through this process and by doing
that is to go through this tackle
process and i thought hey
i'll call it tackle your success you
know how do you you know how do you
become successful after life after
sports because it's not easy but like
sports there's a process to it
nice i like that and what was the whole
process for starting the book did you
just have an idea and the whole process
to go from that idea to get it onto the
shelves
yeah man i think in the book i discussed
when i when i when i left the marcos um
you know i was really i was high in life
i was like man okay i'm 33 i can
hopefully i can get in the hollanders
again maybe maybe not on
you know four four four i mean back in
2012 13 you know that's 33 54 you're
considered old yeah and the southern
hemisphere this is back then yeah and
now you've got guys who are 35 store
playing you know um but in northern
hemisphere where i played you know guys
are in their late 30s 40s so i was quite
uh you know i was quite optimistic but
also uh realistic of hey uh
you know there's much much more guys
there's much more talented players who
are coming up the ranks who are younger
who are hungrier you know they've got
you know a crack at making the all
blacks or the marcos or whoever or the
hollanders so um
so yeah so i think i guess uh
and going through that step
and then and then reaching out for help
because help really didn't really start
with you know it started with
relationships years ago for otago for
guys like david gibson who was working
for new zealand rugby players
association at the time also josh blacky
so guys already i had trust with me for
many years playing alongside each other
so i knew them they really transitioned
into their careers
and and they were quite you know they
were in touch with me to see what i was
up to
so i think one thing led to another and
uh i guess just
and you know just leaving the room
uh because you know when you're when
you're stuck by yourself you're not
really surrounded by a team you know
becoming it can become quite lonely but
i have family who
didn't really know what was happening uh
my wife was really patient uh she didn't
even know what was happening
uh i didn't know what was happening um
so i guess you once you go down this
spirits is you need to sort of reach out
straight away and and and get in touch
with those guys who are who want to talk
to you like the gibbous
josh blackies and and family and friends
who were there
and they pretty much started the process
um and they inspired me to hey i need to
write this book because i know there's
one or two others who might be going
through the same process as i went
through so when you finished did you
finish uh footy on your own terms
yeah i did i did yeah i had a uh it's
the end of the marcos 2012 i got offered
to go to france
uh in 2013. yeah i was thinking i don't
want to leave and learn another language
i can't really speak french so i can say
yeah bonjour yeah
but but that's about it you know
um
so yeah i had to weigh it up and i
didn't want to go back and flat with
other guys or stay with other people
yeah
so that's pretty much where i said no
i'll go through this process through the
new zealand play association with a
careers advisor um so once that happened
uh that was it i made my decision no
i've got a plan i want to become a
work in education with adult learners
and you know with challenging
backgrounds and that was mainly in south
auckland which i i based myself in
auckland
and then i transitioned into schools
with kids for four years so working with
kids so um
but i didn't know that i wanted to start
a school because i wanted to how can i
help kids become
you know get more opportunities you know
education
uh and also wanted to become a speaker
so those were the two things uh my
career chris advisor told me she said
okay you want to go in the education
pathway but you also want to become a
speaker like a tony robbins or oh yeah
yeah he's awesome he's awesome that
guy's awesome so i thought yeah i could
be there someone that that's that sound
more motivational speaker but i thought
oh okay do i get paid for it
wait hold up so
yeah i think you just i was just bit
naive of what was happening yeah at the
time um
you know and i guess i had to go through
that
to go into the corporate environment for
for nearly two years uh working in south
auckland at a private private training
establishment
and that was tough that was tough man i
mean i've never come across uh
micro management
i've never come across
guys who are
all about themselves you know the the
eye there's no there's no team and a lot
of corporate environments yeah
frustrating really frustrated
uh there was no feedback sessions like
the monday reviews we get hey james
um everyone was just sort of like uh
they went accountable um
so i found it really hard because the
values of sports and and and and
corporate environment were aligned but
not really it was different
everyone's everyone's on a different
different sort of uh yeah they're in
different pathway and uh a lining that
is is challenging
so yeah so yeah that's a bit of a yeah
some of uh the reason why i wrote mate
that's interesting an interesting
insight into the corporate world so how
long was that process from when you were
when you finished rugby to when you felt
comfortable and what you were doing
post-footy
pretty much uh three months three months
oh yeah
three months so
um because once that once once when that
time when when i had no no contract
from about january
february january i thought oh no there's
no money coming in the bank yeah uh
hold up there's no uh there's no yin
coming in or no uh or no
or no oh oh
they call it
or no tyler's coming in
um
so
and that's when things you know you you
tend to put a panic you know a bit of
panic oh no oh
did i have enough can i survive for the
next six months
um but then when i reached out uh after
a few weeks of just trying to do it
myself because it doesn't work yeah it
doesn't work just just don't try to try
to try to solve yourself if you're in
the situation
do reach out to guys like like i
mentioned before
and and uh
yeah and just be really it is a
a vulnerable time um and it is hard for
mainly i'm not saying i'm not being
stereotypical about males to reach out
and speak up
and and ask for help so that's the
that's the challenge that i had but i
knew i had to do it because if i didn't
you know things would have went
spiraling out of control um
so but when it happened
one month two months and three months i
was i was excited i was excited to work
to work the nine to five grind yeah
i was just going every day to to
practice every day
and this book tackle your success if you
could sort of give us a preview like a
little bit like the movies and you see
the shorts what what would this book be
about
uh oh i'll give you a wee little look
at that
yeah mate
so that's the the front cover
uh that's that's better the the
background of what i have um
but about me and
what i'm about now so
so pretty much the i have
um i've sort of sort of
um
throughout the book i've mentioned about
sort of seven truths of of a
professional rugby player
um
so you know some cemeteries that you you
will know james and i and i wrote it
last year
and it went to a quite viral and i think
mighty banks
i think he shared it
and i thought okay cool oh i might use
it because it was trending on facebook
and instagram so i use that to as a as a
subtitle just here yeah um so okay so
it'll be quite interesting um
and you know if i was looking at some of
those truths uh i'll give you probably
one or two
uh maybe three i'll read the book um
audio book
audio
amazon audio pocket so
i think uh i'll give you the first three
so seven truths are very very badly i
mean you're an injury away from losing
your job a hundred two
two your performance is scrutinized
daily
three
you're only borrowing the jersey oh
three powerful ones give us the next
four no uh
next four oh jordan no you're sorry mate
you're like you gotta pay for that
if you've gotta pay for that brother
[Laughter]
you know like most things mate that's
taken me a while to you know think about
these things you know for for forward
you know we we're deep thinkers
very deep thinkers in the scrum in the
line outs we've in the malls you know we
think really deeply about these things
uh james unlike your backs who just kick
the ball and you know have your cup of
tea
so did you write this yourself or did
you have a ghost right or how did it
work
no pretty much i wrote it all myself i i
did get an editor right at the end of
the process just to check my spelling
you know spelling mistakes
but there's american guy that was my
editor
so i said hey uh it's it's uh new
zealand english news in english
so i had to make sure so if you do see
anything that's american in there hey
hey
it's my bed
i'll take the responsibility uh because
i didn't explain or communicate properly
so
uh yeah so um yeah i had an editor i had
a a designer
to to to design the front so it does a
bit of a process
uh i've also um i've got my my framework
in there the tackle framework
uh which i might give you a sneaky look
i'll give you a sneaky look james yeah
of course
oh look at that that's sorry that's it
that's it if you want to see more you
you've got to go through uh gotta go
through uh through me to get it so uh
anyway yeah um so yeah so a few people
have designed it um
to help me with their process of
doubling my thoughts into a nice picture
to make it easy because like make things
uh you know keep things simple
easy to read so i wanted to write it at
a level
where people who are 10 to 12 year old
reading age can read it yeah so
as most writers if you're reading
something that's
great for regular players i mean if it's
too high level james you know it's
academic or anything
it's just too much thinking yeah
just get put off and put it down
how do guys buy it how do we buy it
yeah right so uh i'll have a open link
next week so it's um so open carts i
think next week 16 for february
uh so you just need to go to tackle
yexyoursuccess.com so
it's live on the 16th of february so
don't go now because it's not live so
so 16th uh february is when it's open
cart
um and pretty much then you can go order
from there and then
yeah so
so you're looking for look looking
forward to that right looking forward to
getting my hands on one and i'm sure
most of the listeners are especially
after that little teaser matt you've
sold that very very well
oh
quite interesting i've mentioned a few
stories of the hollanders samoa with
marcos
uh
my my my uh my challenges in japan
uh
different coaches of sort of clashed
against and
like not in new zealand but in new
zealand but also overseas just
you know values down the line you know
this is really interesting i've just had
to write that and done my thoughts and
and really think about these things but
also being sensitive of who they are
yeah uh and donna's sort of uh out
everyone else you know helps them out oh
you know
this person did this to me you know it's
not a i don't want to be like a feel
sorry for me
because it's not
it's not it's about it's more about what
happened
and uh and and what did i do next
well i know we're not going to be able
to hear all those stories on here but
i'd like to hear a few of them and i'm
keen to hear through your um
rugby journey which you might you played
for so many different teams so you must
have some stories from those times but
like all good stories need to start at
the start uh where did you grow up
so i was uh my parents when they came
from samuel well i was i was born in
upon huntley oh yeah
and an old um and down hamilton
um so that's where so we were the first
generation when we came and uh so
parents raised us here and then left uh
hamilton when i was young and came to
auckland
and did primary school up here
and then uh i'm glennons
and then when i was 10 years old
my father
uh decided to
go back to university or go to
university when it was 40 odd years old
so he went to study um
uh theology to become a minister
so he went down so we packed our bags
and then we drove to downtown dundas
when i was 10 and then
pretty much stayed there i went to
intermediate down there dna i didn't eat
north intermediate uh stayed in opoho
and pine hill
and then went to logan park high school
which my older siblings went to so i was
sort of
encouraged to go there because my
siblings went there so
i thought it was great it was great
looking pack was awesome uh awesome
athletes were there chris donaldson mark
pickle
um
you know you got some uh
also uh i think uh belinda colling was
there i think
uh so yeah so you have some um some
great athletes there um but when i got
to about 15 16 i wanted to to go to
a uh to take a boys
so that's when i um i i made the leap um
which was interesting because you're
going from a coed school
to to a boys school so yes i left there
and i went to obs and uh that pretty
much
started my my serious rugby journey
that's when i took rugby quite seriously
the change of skills wasn't because of
rugby
no it was just rugby it was just rugby
yeah yeah i mean i was here i wanted to
i wanted to because i missed out on
i missed out on the tiger 18's oh i
missed it i missed out on the teams
tiger 16
south island team so i was a bit
upgraded i thought oh am i going the
wrong school am i
you know who you know who doesn't like
me uh am i not playing in the right
position yeah i should i should go back
to i should go back to winger
um
so
um
yeah so it's just one of those things i
was quite um quite stubborn at the time
i need i said no i need to go to toggle
boys had a few a few good mates who went
there
uh and then that's when i i bumped into
richie mccoy
um you know and um
and yeah and uh cll eric knows some of
the guys there jason cowbell
uh ryan martin reimarda was uh was i was
our our captain um
and uh so there's our little half pick
so just
so um yeah so now he's coaching him
rebels which is great now
so what was richie like at um that age
right he was he was a bit odd he was a
little odd
um
but look like with most oddballs i think
he was quite highly intelligent
and uh i remember one time when i think
it was 96 or 97 were on the bus
and uh it was me tom palmer
he was english guy he played for england
i know he's scottish but he played for
england yeah that's right yeah so um
and and a couple of senior boys at the
back and then he came sat at the middle
and the guys were saying oh yeah that
guy um yeah that that that skinny kid
this oh who richie yeah he's he's like a
a plus student said a person what
a plus in
physics
you know uh
calculus and mess and saying hey
and then
first i was thinking man this is weird
um and then
and then he played and um
he just you know he had a great great
return uh great reputation for his uh
who was a work ethic back then um
and you know not surprised of what he's
achieved you know because i saw we all
saw it at school because he stole
everything pretty much
um
you know from the ground up you know
he'll chop tackle steal the ball and
he'll give it to me to run thank you
um
so yeah it was uh yeah but we had a
great team back then um and we went on
to actually to um
to you know uh to beat the likes of
crotchish boys and christ college
yeah those guys we actually had to play
iron ore high school in a south island
the school's final um
yeah so and then i went along and we won
the uh new zealand schools uh top four
uh which we we drew of rotorua but we we
won it so
it's a share title
so we became the the first uh south
island first of the team to to actually
uh to have their trophy crazy and what
were you like as a player
oh well i was quiet pretty much uh
massive pretty much i was pretty
no i don't know
i'm not sure if it's massive i just uh
yeah i played number six i was flanking
a blunt side flanker yeah so richie was
seven
uh eric no sir was our eight uh so we
had quite a good good leaf for
uh loose trio
um but yeah so i don't know i guess i
just um
you know uh you know run hard tackle
hard you know just use you know use what
what what my natural strengths were and
also to you know to use it for the team
i guess and i just yeah
you know use that to
to
you know to
you know to help the team
most of the time did you always think
you're going to have a career in footy
um not really because i missed out
i missed out on all the age group teams
uh
when i was 17 18 i missed out on an
under 18 a tiger team
when i left school i missed out on the
tiger 19 team i missed out on the tiger
schools
secondary schools uh pretty much mister
to know that all those teams
national rep teams
um
but i did make the south island schools
team which which is cool which is uh you
know um
and i guess that really drove me to to
set some standards for what i would do
next because back at the high school i
had long hair all right so
i had long hair so it was quite
interesting because we used to play la
when was the play up in crush boys or
christ college they said i say hear them
call me malby
bro first thing that's wrong because i'm
not maori i'm someone so and uh yeah i
got long hair but i'm sure maori didn't
have long hair
so
anyway so so i think when i have school
actually i actually cut my hair i cut up
chopped it off
and then i got the whole fade on and i
think those are that was the beginning
of of my uh you know pretty much my uh
my career so
get focused get tidied up
set some goals and uh and play for my
beloved alambro union rugby club after
school and you've still got the fade
today mate
look at the face
bro you know what i've been i've been
practicing during this uh during these
lockdowns where no barbers so i've gone
back to the gone back to the two the
threes just
hey it's the process bro it's a process
three years of lockdown journey
but you mentioned you didn't
make many of the rep size but then you
did make the new zealand under 21s
didn't yeah which was a stacked side
looking back at that team these days how
did you find going into that team
yeah i'll be before that so um
i guess i was sort of
phil young was sort of watched me
when i was in 99 at club rugby and he
encouraged me um even though we're
getting getting smashed
60-80 points every week by by you know
club rugby by the way cpas who were
stacked with hollanders to even varsity
b beating us
you know so and this is a premier team
and you know and we're always second to
last for a few years
uh which is not bad the second to last
is good
and then the beginning of 2000
2000 is when i got um invited to play
a trial for the high on the colts
and then
uh and then that's when i pretty much
yeah start to change my mindset so okay
i've got there's there's a there's a
goal here you know to play well get on
the team we got on the team and then we
ended up winning the hollanders
uh the new zealand new zealand um super
rugby colts competition
and then um and then from that got
picked for the new zealand uh two on
colts
trials and then went to that
a couple of trial games we were ruthless
troll games and then
they made the new zealand team which was
here which is a was a massive highlight
so yeah you're right yeah we'll stack
we'll pretty much looking back now
because it was a stack team yeah yeah
so many all blacks say so many
professional rugby players who made a
career out of it so um was there anyone
at the time who really stood out to you
like man this guy's gonna be
good i think um
um
jc jerry collins um you know so you know
who
uh so so the brother then back then he
was um
he was a leader you know he was a leader
um
and i knew him because i played him i
played him in the in this in the cent in
the regional tournaments yeah and i used
to i used to i said clash royale because
he was number eight i was number eight
for south island team i don't care who
he was he was with chris my soy with the
flankers for central regions
and we said just clash bang bang it was
awesome it was awesome
but you know it's pretty soon afterwards
and then and then making the couple
years later and then um
making the new zealand cults team
together i remember one one time where
we we played samukotes and north harbour
at the ball champs and
and samuel were just hammering us they
were just smashing us and we were only
up by maybe two two points at half time
um
and we got into the changing rooms at
north harbour stadium and
and we sat down quietly and all i can
hear was jerry collins just swearing his
head off
you know meaning are we scared
are we scared what the pepe
what are we doing
and he just challenged us you know he
just
put his foot down
saying this is not good enough you know
we're not we're not playing for the
jersey we're not playing as a team we'll
we're playing as individuals we're
allowing them to to come at us you know
we need to go out there and change
things
second half
went out there pretty much rode up our
sleeves
moored them you know really you know we
pretty much grinded them out in the
second half and when we won by about not
my mouth by 15 points which wasn't by
much but uh the sound war team were you
know like most of them played rugby here
in new zealand so they missed out
premium cults so there's always that
motivation to to smash us so so and we
all pretty much went to the same school
as everyone else so i think there's
their motivation there as well so it's
very hard playing against the brothers
you know going to school here um because
you know there's extra you know extra
feeling there um so yeah i think jerry
collins really stood out as a leader to
really you know really uh you know
really say how it is how it was
um and everyone just listened
powerful powerful jerry from a very
young age and then you made otago
year 2000 so we'll set about 22 years
ago i know how much rugby's changed in
the last sort of 10 years i can only
imagine how different it was back then
so what was it like for you going into
the otago environment as a young fella
22 years ago
oh goodness me uh mate i was
so after the the new zealand colts i um
i actually i didn't make the otago mpc
team
i actually i was in the bees the uh the
old killer bees the tiger killer bees
um and then
halfway through the season i got caught
in to cover in the epc squad top side
and then i got caught in again to uh
reserve against the canterbury
uh team um which was a ran through the
shield again
and uh that was exciting i was wow this
is renfrew shield um you know you got
both teams were pretty much
you know full of all blacks and um and
players were played for other
other countries and i'm going to play it
play at the old jade stadium
or the older the old lancaster
park and
and in the first
10 minutes of the game
john
blacky got injured a lock or beagle
so bigger got injured the first 10
minutes of the game
they said felipe you're up
what
but then i was just you know i'm 20.
well i was 20 21. i was just looking
around i was just you know i was just
admiring that i was just soaking in the
atmosphere because it was a pack stadium
was probably 30 000 there i was just wow
this is awesome um
and then he came off and i had to go on
and mark
mark toblacker
oh great this is the uh this is the all
black captain
so uh and we
ended not long after i came on cal
hammond came on after after me so one of
my props got injured i think it was case
museum got injured so we both came on at
the similar time so
and then we um
yeah that was an awesome game so and
then we we we lost in the last minute
you know uh caleb ruff scored
right in the last dying minutes of the
game to to win against us so
um but i guess yeah that was an
eye-opener of of really high performing
um you know a little higher the height
of playing at a high level with uh with
all blacks and other internationals
and i guess that was a stepping stone
i've really wanted to push forward and
reach reach high goals yeah did you get
a lot of confidence out of that game and
did you feel like you'd earn
your teammates respect after that
performance
i mean it's really hard because you know
as a young guy you don't want to go in
there's a young guy and tell everyone
what to do yeah so especially back there
pretty much all of them
yeah it was still it's always the
culture back then that it was pretty
much old school called old school
mentality
uh there was you know there was a there
was a there was a lot of drinking yeah
but also there was quite a
sort of a top down approach i guess um
and
you know um but this is just me that's
just me looking from a youngster and
maybe it's just me being
being young at the time but and you know
trying to kick in and respect because
it's hard to gain respect with guys
who've been here for five six seven
years and they've worn the black jersey
or won the blue jersey uh the homeless
jersey for years so
um
yeah so it's uh
yeah i should have answered that
question
with any players who made it difficult
for you or made it easy for you sort of
took you under their wing or um guys who
were just like oh
being nightmares to you making it really
difficult
i do remember brian i'm sure with
brownie tony brown you uh no that's just
that i got caught in the hollanders in
2001 i was in the uh honda under 23s
uh i got it i was i was gonna didn't
make it but hey i've gotta go go for
that pain
um anything according to the holders to
uh for the last few weeks and i went to
one of the first training
and i had to uh
i had to hold the bags and the brownie
was getting into me yeah he was just
smart it was trying to smash me i was
thinking
i was just going sort of i didn't want
to go too hard on them you know because
because you know he because he's the
he's the so-called kumato yeah you know
you know so as a young guy you know you
know gonna be you know be humble and be
respectful of the of the elders and like
okay i'll just i'll let him i'll let him
have this
but you know but you know but i um
yeah i mean he's you know like brownie
he's he's highly
uh competitive you know um so if you're
not and you're if you're not there 100
mentally physically prepared for what's
going to happen then
then yeah watch out so this is that's
something that i i'll learn to make sure
i come prepared
uh you know most of the time most of the
time
was there a massive step up from the
highlanders from otago to the
highlanders back then because you still
had a lot of your all blacks playing
for the otago so what was it like going
into that highlanders environment was
that a pretty easy transition
oh goodness uh oh
no no oh well
so yeah the back in so 2001 was when i
made the npc team otago
and uh that's when laurie mains came
came in the picture oh yeah
so older older lori
uh one one-on-one coach uh tiger um
coached over cats and super rugby in
south africa
so he had a reputation as a hard man i
didn't really know who was
only by watching you know watching the
old uh all blacks in the 90s mid 90s
so and i knew he he
you know he had an interest in me
he knew what i did in the colts which
was good he knew a bit of my background
and he sort of was sort of um
um
sort of molded me into that player that
he wanted to be in 2001
so which is that um
uh you know be that sort of that that
thai headlock
you know someone who can you know who's
able to have a higher work rate is able
to
use power strength you know and and then
do my job to do the simple things well i
think
uh and on top of that is
ensure that
that you're fit
and uh when i say fit there's a there's
a different level of fitness for flori
and i think uh one of the
and he was known for in the all blacks
is for his uh 150 meter sprints
which which i came accustomed to for a
couple years
so i guess that was the biggest thing
for him uh
aerobic capacity of of players to have
their aerobic capacity to last the
distance and and more
but also the mental toughness
at the same time as a young player
looking back at it i can see what he was
trying to do
really old school running um and you
know and it worked because you know
we're always in the top four we're
always making finals
uh but we always came against uh you
know the crusaders and crusaders always
had their bit of x factor they always
had that one percent difference
where they could you know win in the
last five ten minutes or or get a
penalty which
which which was something that we were
trying to learn as a group in a culture
um
so yeah i was eye-opening going into the
super rugby environment because laurie
wanted high standards of
and his uh pretty much his of his video
reviews and this is what i actually
write about in the book we've been in
the book about it
uh of of uh pretty much outing guys and
and video video from review sessions
uh so it's a bit it's a bit like uh kk
high remember
so so when someone else sorry so fast
forward years later so when i was in the
marcos when when when kk started doing i
just laughed because it just reminded me
of lori
but then when he did it when he did it
he he'll look towards me look towards me
and cameron johnson and he'll give us a
bit of a wink
[Laughter]
so here's us enough you know our nearly
mid 30s
and you know saying you know
thinking yep we we had that we had that
keep going
and in some ways you i think you as
young guys i think males i think males
we need their hard line approach
we need accountability
uh but now
but now it's it's coaches now need to
have it and adapt to the player so i
think that's what i've learned yeah
definitely you're right i mean that hard
approach is isn't for everyone but um it
does definitely work for some people you
hear people's um
when they look back at their times with
kk some people love them some people
hated them it was just depending how
much feedback they could handle i loved
it because it was awesome oh me too man
i found him good value right he would
not beat around the bush with telling
you how you
played a
i think you know i think there's a
there's a
perception that this generation are
quite soft which i don't know i don't
think that's true i don't think that's
true it's just
different generations different
technology different culture different
you know the society is changing people
are changing we'll become more diverse
so
i think the likes of kk we we sort of
need that kkk now and then so
you know it's you know the old uh
good cop bad cop yeah you know 100 uh
you know it's it's playing but also
you know you look at the great teams
across the world to uh to manchester
united you know to look at ferguson's
you know his uh successes and i was
really you know watching one of his uh
his movie you know um and you know he
mentions about
going really hard on a couple but then
being soft on others who may be
who may be the the ones who actually
cause trouble on the team yeah because
you know like he was that was that was
cantona so cancer now you know the
french guy said he was
you know highly emotive uh stereotypical
french you know
uh he'll do anything he would just
uh do whatever he wants to do but
managing that play and that was really
tricky for him fergie fergie yeah um
so i think successful of the successful
coaches um
you know who are able to manage their
players
uh you know their personality traits uh
even those who
um you know who
are different to others who
know you have players who
uh who were speaking up more i think on
social media which was was never there
when i was there it was just back in the
day was this
give me a call
oh yeah i'm i'm number i'll meet you
oh i'll meet you at the mall
oh i'm going to meet you at the spacey
parlor
yeah so times are different but uh
just need to adapt
and one one thing that it's come up a
few times and the questions about your
highlanders career is your incident with
justin harrison a fair bit of biffo on
the field and post the field apparently
i'd love to hear the story about this
one
no no that was just still just silly
that was just silly that was
um
oh goodness those are those the royal
towers worldwide 2000 and
2004 i think yeah
2004. i remember because i don't get
many red cards that was probably my only
root cause
in my 250 games uh
prove one or maybe two maybe
hey that's not a bad standard not a bad
status one for someone who hit as hard
as you
there is not bad you would have had a
few more actually these days i reckon
with the
head actually oh actually
actually i was pretty close in japan
because in japan when you tackle tackle
hard the
straight away you'll give you a yellow
card
so hey i just i just smashed them mid
and then
and around the mid area too hard
if you had you can't do that as a as a
gaijin so yeah you're going to be you
know how you've got to respect the the
culture
so going back to uh that question
if i get started in the ruck area there
was a bit of biff and hitting you know
there's forward to do because you your
backs just do nothing
you know working hard in there
and then something happened
um
you know a bit of a breath bit of a grab
me i'll grab you yeah and bit of you
know he sort of sort of did this and i
did that and then one thing led to
another
punch punch punch you end up on the
ground
yeah it's just a little silly and we got
up
and then
i got the red card he got a yellow card
that did not make sense
did you get him better than he got yeah
was that why
i don't know yeah i'm not sure
i'm not sure man but uh no that wasn't
i'm not sure maybe i was the aggressor
i'm not sure i wasn't i mean we both
ended up on the ground came back on on
the back on the feet and
yeah
[Music]
and then
and that was not the end of the story
now the good part
out of it
you'll probably
the good part you'll probably find it
uh no it's not in my book not in my
book if you know you think you'll have
to go profile on youtube somewhere uh
yeah a couple of things happened after
the after the game was
again it was a highly emotive game we uh
we were down we i was playing with 14
men for the rest of the second half
actually wasn't the first of second of
year you know originally the second half
and
and pretty much we we have the amount
and uh they had a penalty
uh matt burke had a penalty to win the
game about 40 out on the right yeah of
the post you know this is matt burke
will be legend
99
probably
you know kicker you know
you know he could pretty much be
blindfolded and just throw it over
uh anyway
he lines up and he's me on you know just
at the bench of my suit
oh no if this goes over
you know i'm going to feel so
you know
i'll i'll just fail
i'll let the team down again you know
it's like a double blow you know i've
let them down because i got red red
carted and he gets this is like a double
double blow so
so he lines up and i'm looking at them
and i'm
anxiously waiting crowds quiet
and he walks and it goes through that
straw as your backster going to kick the
ball
and he kicks it
and it hits the post
that's the pose and the ball bounces
well bounces off the post
and then neil brew catches it and he
kicks it out
came over around the field i saw justin
harrison they gave him a bit of a shove
give me i kept charging
and he sort of came to me and the
security guards got in the way and then
bit of pushing shove in that was it
yeah so uh yeah
so i think in hindsight um
that was that was probably a a pretty
silly thing to do don't don't do that if
you are if you're playing right now
uh if you're in france yeah you can do
this it's normal friends
i was just excited i was just like oh my
goodness maybe just
go good old uh get out of get out of
jail cut 100 oh that's a good one love
it and did you ever get close to the all
blacks
yeah so uh i
uh after the the crusaders uh semi-final
we
obviously we
we lost to the last sort of 10 minutes
of the game um
and then the next day
um you know pretty tired you know big
celebrations the night before you know
after super 12 season and
and then i got a random phone call
and all the old john mitchell
um
you know
what wasn't that was on the line so i
said oh hi um john mitchell here um
blah blah blah sort of i was slightly
awake trying to wake up from my
big night
um
so he so he calls and um and he talks
about uh my season i went i went really
well
and he said look uh we've not picked you
for for the old blacks but uh we'll
watch on standby
uh i said oh hey yeah awesome i thank
you for the opportunity yeah cool blah
blah blah blah and then and then that
was it
um so back my head i cool there's an
injury i'll be in the team and i went
back uh
back on
what was it super sundays
back in the sunday and then monday and
then you know recovery
et cetera and then
and then a few few weeks later i
i i went to play for a lamborghini i
came to green on
and then i twisted my ankle uh quite
quite severely so
i went to the
to the physiotagophysio and then and at
the same time uh the boys were saying
that the the all blacks have caught up
another lock
um
so uh i i knew
with a conversation that that would have
been me so i think the the lock was
normal maxwell he got injured in the
2002 game so the game coming up was
against the springboks and london
uh so yeah so i'm just taking it from
the call when he went when he said i was
on standby that i i was the next one too
to get in so
uh but you know so i waited one year
second year three years four years
am i still on standby
[Laughter]
well by then by then henry took over
so uh
uh
there's most things where you just go
through this
okay yeah you go through this uh you
know as most players they
think okay uh what's what's next yeah uh
yeah so i think you've got to just find
what next so i also always had a vision
you know to play posamo as a youngster
um
you know always admired um you know the
91 team 95 in the 90s you know there
were great teams so um spoke to michael
jones michael jones
and then uh one thing led to another so
i met with him
he had a vision for the team and then i
i tried went to play with childhood
samoy and then and that's when their
journey started for samoa but before
that i played for pacific island yeah
that's right in 2004 so that gave me a
bit of a
bit of a sort of view into the um
rugby what was that team like because
that was teams from all the different
pacific islands coming together how did
it all work
bro i mean um
it was uh it was a special team
it was just i mean i was
you know i was in my sort of early 2023
um
you know and all the guys 89 of the guys
were playing for sam or all for fiji or
for tonga
so they've gone through the years of
pain of hurt
of you know of you know of no money
you're not getting paid
uh paying for themselves the trials all
these issues i was hearing because
there's something i did not experience
in new zealand you know here
everything's everything the system here
is everything's done you know with
professional you know off-field is taken
care of
of the time you know and then players
just focus on their on what they need to
do on the field
um however in the pacific islands it's
quite it's quite complex with the
political environment but also the
cultural
environment as well as uh
as values
as well so uh money is not a it's not a
big driver for players to come back play
for the islands
it's because you actually lose money
going back
because you pay your effort then you
have to you know you provide for your
family you need to serve your family
when you're when you're there so
it's like oh do i go back this year
[Laughter]
so um and then getting in the team i'm
making the team you know i was so happy
i was stoked and
i met the likes of um
uh goodness me sort of a semo titi you
know who's the captain of samoa
uh to siro rambini who are playable for
the holidays uh in otago yeah siri
rambino uh he's passed away
um
you've got guys like um
sunil
another player who's passed away and he
was on the team
he was in there
so these guys were just in the cusp of
the all blacks and they and the team
here guys like norman langari uh
lingerie sorry if i didn't pronounce it
wrong to the fijians
uh to uh cerrito and bumble yeah
you know these throw these and we
like every time we used to play like
like fijian touch
waste of time
waste of time bro you ain't going to get
the ball from the future
and and this is just this is just fuji
in touch you know
we're trying to touch them it's just you
just you know like that like that and
oh so it's just the skill level and i
think just the the natural talent but
the hard work hard work effect
and and the in the under in the
the the the collective um
team around you know the click the
values that we had really aligned with
each other and that's why we i think
that's what we'd really charred within
two weeks to get ready for the wallabies
spring blocks and the all blacks
so yeah now that was a it was a special
team very different to the modern
pacifica team because majority of them
have not played for the islands
uh where most of these guys are you know
we were born in the islands raised there
they know that they've gone through
their hurts and so they
they had the extra you know the extra
motivation to really do well for for the
pacific island in 2004. and there's some
freakish talents in that side like
you've already mentioned was there
anyone who you're just like wow this guy
is an absolute freak
oh god so there's just too many
so it was quite funny james um
because we are that widow but we had a
simple game plan
so uh we were
we're tonga
we had samoa in fiji
so those were three main attacks
so tonga was pretty much
same way
pick and goes power so the pick and goes
in the middle power through the rocks
around there
and then samuel was runners you know
you've got your runners you know you're
you know off off the 10 or off nine yeah
you know coming off there
and then fiji was wide too wide
so you're going back and forth and
you're just gonna see space finds fine
space
so really simple and um
and you know some freakish guys were
like um like
oh yeah paper sambal yeah
he was the first five he was he could he
also he was a
a uh the magician he was like a cruden
uh rick you know uh moana um
so he was he was really talented he
could see things that you know as most
things forwards just saying just go go
forward but you know he was naturally
gifted with a vision to do things
and to you know able to create gaps for
the fijian guys samoan guys they pretty
much crash through the middle
other guy was benny
um he was
he was special that guy i mean he had
him he had a big impact in in leicester
tigers in europe frankly winning
heineken cups and you know those
premiership cups so
so what what inspired your move to japan
was it because the all black dream was
sort of over or
wanted to go get some yen
uh well i think
i think as most uh players we come to a
point i was 28 by then yeah um no
actually i was 27 when we had the
conversation which was about 2016 when
we had the conversation with them they
they flew me over the club uh and we had
a bye week in nbc so they flew me over
um
uh well if they flew us over sorry and
then we stayed in the uh in shibuya
hotel which is flash so so there's a big
difference to staying in a
you know staying in the uh the octagon
uh hotel oh hey sorry there's nothing
wrong with the needed hotels um i was in
a different you know smack bang of tokyo
and then went to the club caught up with
a couple of the kiwi guys uh when wayne
macker went mackenzie he was there uh
they met with us the coaches
the junior manager and then
threw us back and then uh i didn't sign
then um so i met the hollanders again
and then it was until the end of the
hollanders i thought i met michael jones
i'm i i
rico has the company rico has has come
back with uh with an extra 30 40
increase of the contract
i think bro
okay okay okay let's go this is it so
everything was sort of you know you know
you know it's a bit of that the domino
effect you know sort of
oh that's all that's you know the old
the snowball effect you know so like
everything's working everything's
working okay i need to i need to take
this because a bit of a bit of a
momentum for my career there's a there's
a shift here that's happening i need to
i need to make a decision now
so signed the contract
uh my last year for the hollanders
i pretty much went to samoa so it was a
change of new things were happening at
the same time exciting as well and i got
married married and it's all messed and
this whole mess of the situation
um
and then
yes i went to japan
tough
tough with my partner for my wife
um
not easy uh and then second year
had an australian coach was quite
difficult
which i wrote in my book it was that
uh i can't say okay that's in the book
we've got to wait they've got to pay for
that one yeah well really yeah i'm sorry
yeah so
it's actually not in the book i've just
spread this coach from from here
but you know it was just i think there
was misalignment with um
with who we thought i was
because we've never met each other so i
didn't know who he was
so there's a misconception or he had
another idea of of who he wanted as as
in his team because he was now the head
coach he decides to to pick his team
because he was near the year before when
i was when i signed the two-year
contract
so that could be quite challenging as a
player when you're on the outer you're
like oh okay this this is not nice uh
but you know um and i wrote a little bit
a bit of detail on my book about it what
happened um
nice and then so you went to ospreys is
this because of the relationship with
the aussie coach
oh i just thought i uh well i had done
my i done my done my job there i wanted
to
go to france or go to europe i was i was
getting too skinny in japan
true story i got down to 110
what were you at kgs were you going
there 120.
yeah i was about 122 at the hondas yeah
so i got from 122
down to about 110
and there was a lot to do a lot of we
ran lots we were long training i haven't
runs off where's the bike uh bike around
tokyo i mean i loved it i was so fit
i was just like oh man i could man damn
maybe i should go back and play the
hondas and say hey put me at probably
number 10. anyway um
so
it was just i wanted to know i want
another goal and uh you know we you know
um
uh all sort of nothing to do with the
coach by the end but i reached my goals
for the team
um you know and then uh an ospreys were
a team that uh were able to bring me in
because uh alvin win jones he was the
locked in and
there's another lock that was there they
they were playing for wales so there was
a so i was able to come in and and uh
and take over and that's when i met
those guys like elewin jones at ospreys
uh he was only 22.
but then i was 29 you know 30 and um and
i met up with fellow teeter he was still
playing 36 you know player coach
uh marty holler was playing yeah he was
there or chiefs waikato all blacks and
uh and jamie not brown was here
yeah and uh ello also sorry and also uh
uh damon corona damon corona he was
there he was there good kiwi correct so
there's quite a few kiwis there oh sorry
and andrew hall andrew hall was the
manager andrew who's the blue blue ceo
yeah yeah
how do you find it how do you find the
rugby the lifestyle over there compared
to japan
and wales uh and wales yeah whales
bro um
you know what one one one training
i was just we went to the training
grounds and i was just running and i saw
on the table
uh on the table and there was a there
was a look at like a like a gel like a
hair gel
just on the on the table there
and so i went to i'm not sure with
mighty hollow or jamming up brown and
said bro
who's uh who's uh who's whose hair
product
he said bro that's uh kevin henson's and
uh some of the
some of the welsh boys
so
i was thinking if this happened in new
zealand
man you'll be you'll be if you'll be the
laughing stock of the team you'll be you
know you know the boys will just like
they'll just have you you know uh
so
and that's and they opened my eyes to
the culture in wales because it was all
about the look yeah it was all about
being a celebrity
uh but also
um
another thing that got me was
was that they
were always dark as me you know i'm i'm
i'm brown but these guys were like a
dark brown
dark tan brown i'm thinking man are
these are these samoan guys and whales
where do they get that
how come they're so brown
so that's why i came across a lot of
them were
you know we were
you know were
tan you know we were attending salons uh
you know getting their tan on which is
all good hey it's healthy healthy look
and you know they look great they look
you know they look like the brothers
but apart from that no no they were
great the watch guys were awesome
uh they've had a brand similar to new
zealand rugby loved to run it
uh ospreys were one of the top teams
back then with
wolf cardiff um and you know with the
player of the likes of monster
uh the heineken cup uh
yeah that was eye opener at that really
intense level playing it's a really
closely
matched to playing international rugby
uh playing against the monsters playing
against uh ulsters
um
yeah to
teams around around europe how did that
compare to super rugby back back in
those days was did you feel super rugby
was more or less intense than the big um
heineken cup matches
i think with the super 12 what i've
experienced is that uh and i think the
super aotearoa and
we're going to experience
is that the the local derbies are hard
it's it's hard it's it's hard because
it's it's fast it's it's dynamic it's
powerful it's
it's quick
it's highly skillful players in new
zealand that's because of the coaching
and the talent we have here and the hard
work
and i think that's the big difference i
think
and you can't really compare because
europe is
is similar but there's a
a intensity in the set pieces
is intensity of scrumming for the extra
five ten seconds where
in new zealand it's you know were you
know crouched by bang you're it and gone
yeah always gone
because you know because the backs you
know apparently they they want to play
you know the backs no you know we just
you know give them all uh
so
so that's the big difference i think is
the set pieces i think the line-out
scrums were a huge focus and i think
probably because there's
uh i think the i think the body shapes
of of the european i think it'll be
quite tall as well and quite lanky
um you know so
and i'm not saying that not as physical
but there's just a different uh
dimension of because of the of of their
physical bodies
and and also along with that you have
different
uh guys from romania you know these big
guys coming in you know who love to
scrum and prop and then you bring in
guys from tonga from samoa who played
and and mixed that and you've got then
you've got big bodies so
pretty much you've got a team full of
full of internationals so so that's
where the big differences uh set pieces
the other one as well was the was the
respect for the kicker
uh the kicker went to
to keep the goal penalty it was quiet
really quiet
and here new zealand that's like we boo
like hey but
yeah this is all real really weird it's
just odd it's just really weird i mean
that's your respect over there over here
it's like we try to put them off but
i'm sure as you know the kicker you know
it actually makes you better
yeah you know prove these guys wrong and
uh
um
so there's a big difference but i think
going back to the local derbies that's
tough that's gonna be the toughest games
i've played against the crusaders the
blues chiefs
hurricanes
um yeah they were tough and
but now they're playing them back to
back
yeah you know
so but i'm sure with the new technology
they have the new milkshakes they're
drinking now they were able to recover
in two days i'm not sure back then those
spates and
bit of a pie we're done let's move on
so what inspired the move back to tasman
back to new zealand entertainment
pretty much i um
well i
came back from europe i wasn't i went to
europe to nottingham i went there um who
are playing in in sort of the in the
championship division just below the
premiership so i had two years
for newcastle falcons in the premiership
and i came back here for the world cup
and then
i played those three games for tasman in
2011 a couple games
played for samuel and then i went back
to europe by myself
and i didn't want to do that again
so i was slating with a couple of mates
you know and then
nah
then i came back in july
and then tasman were looking for lock
and i signed a full year off demarcus
uh and i was had a goal to maybe okay
maybe i'll play well and i can probably
try finish back with the hollanders
or you know try getting it because i was
looking at otago back then
but they they were pretty much uh cash
trapped back then they were going
through some some some financial
troubles
um around their period 2012.
so uh so marco's will before that all
that all that all those sponsorship
we're able to get me on board and uh
yeah so that's when i came in um
and i had a vision say okay i can
play well here give back because i drawn
out the year before um
and then i came back to the marcos
and i knew that uh kiran kenny he
entrusted me to to be sort of a mentor
for some of the island for some of the
young young island boys in there yeah i
think uh
you know you know uh
jordan's uh uh the jordans who was it uh
the big d big big tavita
um
and then and then mix the net we got
some you know some of you guys that were
there some of the local lads were there
so just i think we me campbell came in
as that sort of that um
try to try to settle things you know for
for you young fellas just i don't know i
guess you know because whether at
a stage of our life that we will okay
we'll give back do the best we can um
and then see how far we can go
well you definitely done that look at
look at where tasman have got to since
um your little stint what a what an
impact you had
yeah no thank you i was always uh i was
sort of happy to leave tasmania on my no
i wasn't happy we lost to otago in the
semi-finals
uh
i was like come on
um
but then a year after that um i was
driving somewhere and i was i couldn't
watch the final
uh and then i was listening to the final
end and and you know we you know the
testimony won that final in 2013.
i was i was just over the mail i was
thinking wow
and then from then on
i've just been following the the
momentum the the the momentum shift that
the whole
uh the culture shift which i saw you
know i saw these sort of the the seas
with someone
you know years before that before i came
it was so years before that but i think
the coaches
the leadership board you know the ceo uh
you know you guys as a team we were
slowly bringing in
a change of mindset
because i thought man this is you guys
are combining marlborough
and nelson
to two entirely different regions
and and and with massive histories and
then combining that and i knew that was
a massive
uh you know a shift to make in terms of
the people to getting the understanding
and their buy-in i knew that's why we
had to play at marlborough when you had
to pay at nelson because we want to get
the buy-in from the locals we need to
get to gain their trust
and many years later you know you've won
championships you've won two npc titles
you'll
consistently in the top four
and then you'll you know you're creating
you know all blacks uh guys who played
international rugby for tonga
uh you know for other other high
you know rugby teams
so yeah that's yeah so it's been a
yeah it's been a um something that i'm
really proud of to be part of the
markers when i was there
nice and what was the hardest thing for
you once you left um finished rugby what
was the thing you missed the most
i think as most most athletes when they
leave it's it's being around for your
mates it's just being with guys that can
um you know they can keep you uh
accountable yeah because you know guys
we know that guys will call you up if
you're you know if you're being lazy or
if you're not lifting heavy enough if
you're not running your lines if you're
not kicking in the corner james
if uh if you're not getting your lineup
or if you're not screaming hard enough
you know just a lot of those micro
details um
so and then when you when you leave it
you sort of
when you in the book i write about how i
start to reflect on a lot of the values
i've learned
and a lot of the values
that we have in sports
um
they're not really common in
organizations that you work with
um and for us it could be it's common
sense stuff you know work hard you know
sacrifice your be selfless play for your
team play for your mates
and i know you know not all rugby teams
are the same not all sports teams are
the same but i think the values are
uh are similar and i think the
connection with uh with people in
relationships that's something i missed
but also having that banter as well
every banter having and also
uh yeah that's unique because one thing
i know in teams is that
in a circle at the last game of a rugby
game you know we always say you know as
you know you know this is
the last time we'll be in this team this
is probably the last time we'll wear
this jersey this is the last circle that
will be and this is unique this is the
only circle that's similar today next
week will be different
next week next week so when you realize
that you understand
there's you know you don't you don't
take the jersey you know you know
um
you know don't take it
to to mean nothing because for others
you're only borrowing the jersey
and um and that's something i really
realized you know the the uniqueness of
news in a rugby
of pacific rugby and an impact we've had
in the global world
also with coaching as well um
it's huge so so yeah so i miss it
but what i've tried to bridge that gap
is to give back
by
coaching cloud break b
so over the last sort of since 2016 i've
been coaching club rugby
uh
same thing same alignment bit of banter
coaches band you know bit of banter on
whatsapp yeah you know
this this this so uh you know it's just
great because i think back at the
coaches who volunteered their time of
hours hours coaching us as youngsters
hey
it's about i think that's part of us as
as kiwis new zealanders specific people
to
to give back to what others have done
for you so because we don't achieve
anything by ourselves
you know if you've asked yourself you
know
so
what did you achieve by yourself
you know if you really think deeply
about that
you actually peel back the layers
there's always someone there there's
always someone there
so so i guess giving back for me was was
to
go and coach sports teams volunteers to
coach some
um some uh
other at-risk youth i've done that a few
years ago that was challenging because
they were all just swearing their heads
off so it's like
oh my goodness
uh
but now coaching uh coaching means um
a primorbial auckland which is which is
great which is a you know it's
competitive we're hiding competitive um
and then just managing that and this
pandemic which is quite quite
interesting um and seeing what's
happening in the moment yeah so
yeah man so yeah that's what i'm yeah
there's some things that i've missed but
then some things i want to fill that gap
to you know
ensure that you know i could still have
that something similar and also to make
sure that i'm i'm happy and um you know
part of the well-being is
this whole
love that what a lad you are it's giving
back volunteering to the
passing on all your knowledge that
you've
uh picked up over your years but as
always we've gone to our instagram for
some questions and maybe you've come up
with plenty plenty of good questions for
the famous author of tackle your success
first question is it true you want
volleyball spike to rugby ball from
going between the goal post
it is true that i did play volleyball um
so i was i was in the i was in the first
team but i went to nationals but i was i
was never the starter
i was never the starting uh in the
starting team i always i always warmed
up and then the opposition will look at
me
i'll come on and do a massive spike like
a quick a
ball hit it you know massive just scare
them and then i'll go back and they'll
sit on the bench right it was all
psychological
this is our tiger boys
uh yeah so i mean we're guys like
so he played for otago
played in france peru pillow made the
new zealand volleyball team when it was
18. so he was in the team as well so uh
so i'm not sure about the rugby ball
that's probably biddle bruh not me was
that when you could lift guys up to stop
um the ball going through the post
off a penalty did you ever do that
yeah i did i did i uh that was the new
zealand colts game against england
so
north north harbour stadium so i was
just
you know as as as a lock should be they
should be standing near the near the
post you know if you're locked make sure
you stand near the post or you get tied
off by the first five
or the coach so i was just standing near
the near near the near the post and i
and he kicked it from about halfway on
the angle and looked and i sort of
walked i was sort of underneath the post
by then i was looking up
and i was also okay i i can actually
jump up and get this
so i waited and then i jumped up
and i and i and i grabbed it oh i
grabbed it so i tapped it and got it
down
and i looked at it i didn't mark it i
looked around
and then i just ran about 20 meters
so did you catch it
yeah well yeah catch sort of yeah sort
of was right on the right on the road in
the bar so it was sort of like i don't
know so they said that was the sort of
going over but i sort of got it right at
right of the edge i wasn't sure if i was
going to hit the bar or not or go over
but i sort of got it just yeah just
there i mean probably best if you go
watch the video clip i've actually it's
quite funny you said that because i
actually saw it uh saw it last year on
youtube sometime in my older and my old
my older video cassettes
true story ah yes so yesterday
okay next one how often do people mix
you up with ross felipe
no no yeah actually yeah they we we're
more playing yeah we were when i was
here
playing for the hollanders yeah we did
get the mixed up people say ross i know
flipboat uh levy levy and people started
calling me livy just could be last name
libby then philippa and there we flip it
live he's playing on the
so uh
yeah so it did happen
um so people confuse me with the
hurricanes oh you're the guy from the
hurricanes the crusader no no no no no
no no no
same color wrong name
[Laughter]
okay next one hardest person to tackle
in your career
how does
probably the tongans and fijians
any of them
oh
god that's me it was like as like a
playing it's like a a freight train so
it's like a freight train that's going
at 100 miles an hour
so
oh goodness
um
how this person is tackle oh
i think it was actually was probably top
blackener what's that
yeah yeah
because because you know that game i
told you i uh padmana i got caught in in
2000 and then 2001
i i i sort of started i i made my way to
understanding a tiger team and we when i
and we played canterbury in the final
for the npc final and i've been again at
jade stadium
um and so i was marking uh i was making
todd likada
so there was one one time when i knew he
was coming around the corner they hit
midfield and i came to i knew he was
going
and then he came straight at me
didn't stop it was just t-boned straight
at me
right i was i was singing stars well i
attacked with him i was thinking stars
so
so he was so yeah as a as a young guy
then i thought oh yeah i can smash him
yeah he actually pretty much ran over me
um
but i actually actually took him down
but that was
yeah that was so i still remember i
still can yeah i can still remember that
that uh
hit another tackle that people want to
know about was your big hit on jared
hawata
tasman vs taranaki
oh
no that was just
that was a bit of a fluke that was a bit
of a fluke i sort of lined them up from
uh from my blind spot
um
because if i didn't stop them then i
think would have been to try the other
side so
um
and i was sort of also out of position
at the same time
i was saying you know don't do any old
uh good you know what's like what's the
line chord again james what do you call
that line when forwards make
what do you call that
you know there's a line what's called
the fat what's it called oh fat man
track was it
that's no that's the one bro that's the
one
anyway
yes i just i just saw i didn't realize
it was him i just had to stop the ball i
mean i wasn't going for a bucket we just
sort of collided yeah um but then it
wasn't until later on in the game he
actually
he actually came back and he got me
right right over here
[Laughter]
and then i said i said something bro
that was good yeah you got me bro
nice bro
oh yeah so that was yeah it was just
yeah it wasn't intentional it was just
something that was just happened
big body contact okay next one this
one's from a good nottingham man um alex
livington um legend for sarasota alex
he's a winner yeah he said his question
is how good was it playing for
nottingham
rugby in 2011 2012.
oh right that was a wolf old glax
that was a
um so that was after
so those after the salmon woke up so new
zealand so
now that was awesome i like the old uh
the greens they were in here there was a
the green machine
um and i was good there's a few kiwis
there sean romans was there sean romans
uh was there for a good otago man and um
and then glax you know old glax was
there as a coach
uh that was good yeah so yeah hey
so alex if you're listening hope you're
well mate um no i had a great time there
i played i played at my favorite
position was it was eight and six
uh well which was great and um
and then i i sort of
yeah i was
uh playing alongside ceonik uh nikki
kalam funny he was an up-and-coming
tongan player and then when i left he
pretty much made a big name for himself
for leicester tigers so it was good to
meet him but i think we i think we we
went all the way through i think we lost
against uh
london
london welsh
yeah i think the semis were saying and i
think we were up by like twenty point
twenty points to the nil half time
i was running right against them uh
but then something happened in the
second half
i don't know i don't know what happened
anyway yeah that was good yeah nodding i
loved nottingham nice big little town
the guys were great they had some great
great flatmates had um you know have you
had uh
had the ralph uh ralph olivier raphael
frenchman had a oogie oogie um
and i'll show you some romans with my
flatmates and uh and they're good oh
nottingham oh what a spot what a spot
nottingham is
okay next question this one's from the
other mate um t polo
uh best mano samoa story
[Music]
so in the process of going to samoa i i
spoke to
my pursuit
and though mups told me
you know that uh playing for samuel was
different
i had to uh you know adapt to to the
boys and et cetera et cetera
so and then
i said i just why yeah cool that just
means that you know highly skillful did
like super rugby teams go over there you
know
and then and then when i got there to
sabo i did the trial and we had our
first manusa more training
we were going for a warm-up and we did
the old four corners you know there were
four corners you know
one boy here one ball here you know uh
you pass left stay right what is it pass
right stay right past right there it's
positive
and then in the drill
those accounts are probably like six or
eight drop balls
this is an international rugby team
and then i ended the training i said
mups
bro what's happening
and he looked at me and he said welcome
to samoa
[Laughter]
so in my head i'm thinking oh no um
so
so
i'm not saying there's there's i mean
new zealand we have a lot of we have
money resources here coaching resources
to
you know so many people to to volunteer
or you know professional teams here sam
was different because it's limited in
resources so
and they open my mind to the to the gap
at the collaborative because there's no
rugby at the primary school level
there's nothing really
in you know at high school there's any
certain schools play it but it's only
now they're starting to put a system and
i've got a cousin
my cousin she's uh she's she works with
samuel ruby um so she's great she's
starting to uh to um
to uh to implement a system
to you know to make sure that that you
know those skills those micro schools
those basic skills are learned at a
young age where i think here in new
zealand we're very we're very lucky
we'll be you know we have that here
already
at a young age we'll coach to pass this
way past that way we'll coach to two and
one passes will coach to do this so
so a lot of those things open my eyes up
to
to the to the lack of resources in samoa
and um
yeah so that was eye opener yeah just
just saying welcome to samoa it just
made me laugh she's like oh my goodness
me
now he's coaching
yeah yeah and now he's coaching them
okay next one uh what was one piece of
advice your father gave you before any
game
my father
probably wasn't my father it was
probably my mother yeah
probably my mother was my biggest critic
so
she always watched the game she'll say
hey you're too slow
yeah you're too lazy
what happened here you missed the tackle
so uh you know as mothers you know we we
you know we listen with intent we listen
with with empathy like yes
yes so
so but i think just uh i think for my
parents it was just just try my best
that's all just try my best just go out
there and lead the team
just do my best and make sure you pray
okay
so who am i praying for me or them
uh
you know so you know just go through
this so there's not one thing there's
many things i think but i think the the
main theme was just just to do your best
and that's what you account for for for
the team
nice okay last question it's been good
so far i'm looking forward to this one
best piece of advice for someone going
through a career change
probably want to buy my book
it's all in there
it's it's all in here but hey look uh
i think we've changed and whole uh
disruption you know with pandemic and um
i think we've all experienced uh you
know change in different ways and
through sports is will be the same as
business
and also you know there's a thing going
around this terminology called the great
resignation or the great bigfoot
i think people are looking for something
different
but also when it comes back to
to yourself when you're looking for
their change
really
really understand you know um
you know when you
uh understand who are there who are the
people that you know that you can trust
who are those that
who've been there all the way through
um and if you can
get in touch with those guys or if guys
are getting in touch with you right now
who are asking for coffee it's good to
have those chats
really speak to them really open up
because once you open up to someone else
you can start to
offload things in your in your head we
want to get what's in here
you know out there
on a piece of paper when you start to
to meet with a with a career advisor or
career coach or whoever
so really reach out to to those people
it could be if you're in rugby using a
play association here
and you know in places and play specific
associations have have people that can
help you through that process so there
are people there
um you know it's just it's just for you
to actually start to reach out and start
the process so the first thing is to
find out who you know maybe someone can
introduce you to that person
um
but yeah it's just about you just just
reflect of of those who
who can really you know guide you but it
also comes down to the trust because of
me it came down to those guys i
mentioned about josh blacky's the uh
gabo's those guys i've played with otago
the hondas you know we've really i've
you know i've really got their trust in
them because of what we've done together
on the field um
now being off the field
i know their values our values aligned
together so
maybe someone that's in your
in that uh who's gone through what
you've been through who can be
empathetic meet with them meet with guys
who have gone through the transition
because
the
because probably not saying it's the
wrong thing but meeting
seeing those or meeting people who
who uh have not gone through that it's
it's it's different that they wouldn't
have that the empathy for you uh or
understanding at a deeper level
um so yeah so
yes it's really it's really finding that
person that that you feel safe with that
you can talk to
um
yeah so and that's also your partner you
know your husband and wife
your parents uncles aunties there's also
your family members you can start to
reach out
uh your old coach you know guys on
social media james i'm sure james can uh
can give you some tips uh you know um
guys in your you know guys who
[Music]
uh you can really talk to uh for me at
the hollanders there was guys like the
listener uh
the peter sinclair there was dr alex
mckenzie guys who were in the pdm roles
the professional development management
roles those guys
who can who can provide you
a plan
but the plan is only only as good as how
you implement the plan
because there's so much information out
there
but only just takes one or two things to
to to to get the to get things moving
for you so
um
yeah great now i see why you written a
book that is some of the best advice
we've ever had
can't wait to read the full book um that
is some seriously good stuff there but
honestly mate really appreciate you
coming on the podcast i'm sharing your
knowledge sharing your um journey and my
all the best for the launch of the book
really looking forward to getting my
hands up myself and reading it and i'm
sure all the world listeners who have
listened to this episode will be keen to
get hold of it as well
yeah cool yeah awesome uh yeah thank you
uh james you're really humbled and uh
thank you for the listeners for
listening uh the book will be up next
week the 16th um go to
tackleyoursuccess.com
tackleyoursuccess.com it's it's not live
now it's it's open cart on next
wednesday so don't go now it's all
getting all planned and ready for you to
go there and order all your books
and for haley if he's listening or
tipolly you know you're going to order
thousands of them
um so yeah so thanks uh james and thanks
thanks for guys who listened in and uh
hopefully if there's one thing you can
take to apply for your life or to your
playing career or or to change uh you
know then i'm i'm happy you're a lad
appreciate it
awesome mate
[Music]
[Music]